good morning Hank it's Tuesday it's
question Tuesday the day that I answer
real questions from real nerdfighters
that's right no plural today just the
one question hi I'm a 15 year old girl
named Katy no you're not you're John
Green sitting slightly farther away from
the camera right now I realize that but
I'm quoting a 15 year old girl who wrote
us an email oh all right I'm not very
popular how do I get boys to like me
thank you for your question Katy let me
begin by acknowledging that I am NOT an
expert in the field of 15 year old boys
in fact Katy putting aside the question
of how to get boys to like you I don't
know how to get boys to like me Katy I
don't know if you know this but all of
our videos except for the ones that
feature giraffe sex as the center
screenshot are watched by nearly three
times more women than men so Katy my
first piece of advice to you is that if
you want to get boys to like you you
should become a giraffe and then have
yourself videotaped getting your giraffe
recon so Katy from what I can tell there
are about six ways to get 15 year old
boys to like you the first way is of
course to become a giraffe the second
way is to become world of warcraft the
third way is to be something called hot
now Katy I would argue that there are at
least two distinct definitions of hot
there is the like normal human
definition which is that individual
seems suitable for mating and then
there's the weird culturally constructed
definition of hot which means that
individual is malnourished and has
probably had plastic bags inserted into
her breasts now boys may find out how
now but I don't think there's anything
inherently hot about it like I think if
you went back to the 18th century and
you asked a 15 year old boy would you
like to marry a woman who has had
plastic bags needlessly inserted into
her breasts that 15 year old boy would
probably be like what's plastic the
fourth way to get a boy to like you is
to be yourself now I'm contractually
obligated as an adult to give that
advice even though it doesn't work but
yeah be yourself
even though no one has any idea what it
means to be yourself like whose self
would I otherwise be being the fifth way
to get boys to like you is to meet their
expectations by acting like you're an
idiot there's this famous poem by EE
Cummings that partly goes the best
gesture of my brain is less than your
eyelids flutter which says we are for
each other and like nothing against the
quality of that lady's eyelid flutter
but why is it that woman's eyelids are
always fluttering while men's brains are
always working so yeah you can buy into
the cultural constructions that young
women are supposed to be stupid and
awkward an eyelid fluttery which of
course
is totally easy to do because sometimes
you feel stupid and sometimes you feel
awkward and sometimes you want to get
all eyelid fluttery but the great secret
of boys which they are right now denying
in the comments of this very YouTube
video is that sometimes they feel stupid
and sometimes they feel awkward and
sometimes they feel all eyelid fluttery
when you realize that all brains gesture
and all I woods flutter and everybody
feels awkward boys will like you because
we will be scared of your knowledge the
sixth way to get boys to like you
consider different boys Katie I have two
words for you nerd boys Katie I know
that nerd boys don't sparkle in the
sunshine but they're sensitive they're
caring they're sweet they'll do nice
stuff for you they're a little bit needy
I will grant you that they're a little
bit needy oh and lastly let me explain
something briefly to boys gentlemen nerd
girls are the world's greatest
underutilized romantic resource and guys
do not tell me that nerd girls aren't
hot because that shows a Paris Hilton
ask failure to understand hotness hey
they'll see you tomorrow I'm so excited
for song Wednesday I got to do a little
dance dance dance dance dance closing
move